April 23rd a small corner of treasured
things my father's cup my Ethiopian
cross Sam's knife The Libertines ring
yeah so are you curious about these
objects yes
the cup uh it has CD on it because I
bought it at Charles Dickens house in
London and it's a beautiful porcelain
cup that I gave my father for his coffee
and no one was allowed to drink coffee
out of that cup not even me and when he
died my mother sent it to me but it
cracked in the in um in the mail in the
mail it didn't break it just had a
little crack yeah and I I felt like that
was another warning you're not to drink
out of this cup my Ethiopian cross it's
very old treasure it's about 200 years
old
and um Sam's knife Sam Shepard liked to
collect pocket knives and at the end of
his life he had this cigar box and they
were filled with pocket knives
and he um asked me to choose one yeah as
a gift and I asked him to choose it for
me and he chose this particular one
and it's small and I think that he chose
a small one because he's always thought
of me as both tough but delicate and so
I of course I treasure that and The
Libertines ring is the ring that Johnny
Depp wore when he played The Libertine
and I love this movie so much these are
all press precious objects and I'm very
lucky to have
you know the things that I have some of
them are very quite valuable and some
like my father's I have my father's golf
ball the last golf ball that he used and
it's just this battered golf ball but it
was his yeah and he you know he was very
frugal and he would use his golf balls
with Knicks and everything else in them
and I have that golf ball and I wouldn't
give that up for any amount of money
yeah